trust has said you know we're going to
arm taiwan and then pressed by media she
did this in dallas and doesn't quite
understand what she's talking about as
prime minister that will not cut it
hello and welcome to chinese whispers
with me cindy yu every episode i'll be
talking to journalists experts and
long-time china watchers about the
latest in chinese politics society and
more there'll be a smattering of history
to catch you up on the background
knowledge and some context as well how
do the chinese see these issues britain
is about to have a new prime minister
this trust is elected as the leader of
the conservative union in the last
decade the uk has gone from the hyper
friendliness of the golden era under
david cameron very strong and full
relationship to this much more fractious
relationship
very concerned about the appalling human
rights abuse so what will prime minister
trust bring with her when it comes to
the uk's relationship with china
i'm joined today by sam hogg who's the
founder and editor of beijing to britain
an extensive weekly newsletter that
updates subscribers on the latest
flashpoints in this bilateral
relationship i'd highly recommend it to
listeners you can sign up for it just by
googling beijing to britain so sam
welcome to chinese whispers hi cindy
thank you for having me let's start by
considering where the outgoing prime
minister boris johnson has been on china
because during his premiership perhaps
the biggest china move was the banning
of huawei from the uk 5g network but it
feels like he really had to be
pressurized into that so what do we know
about his views on china it's a great
question so boris johnson presided over
the end of the so-called golden era
between the uk and china where the uk
actively worked and welcomed china's
investment into the country
and sought to increase cultural ties
johnson's personal views which he's put
out into the public record are that he
doesn't want to pitchfork away chinese
investment and he is a fervent cinephile
um that has put him at odds with his
cabinet including truss
and increasingly put him at odds with
allies on the world stage he's taken a
very cake-ism approach approach to it uh
in the surprise surprise surprise
surprise a classic johnson approach um
he doesn't see the world potentially in
as black and white as someone like liz
trustwood
so i mean let's talk about liz trust
then last week sources on her campaign
said that she'd revisit the integrated
review which is this british government
strategy as it were to foreign policy
that was published last year let's trust
that she said that she would revisit it
to declare china a threat instead of the
systemic competitor that it currently
says china is so safe to say that she's
tougher on china than boris johnson i
think that's exactly right that's a
natural continuation of where she has
effectively set her uh set out her stall
over the last
year and a bit as foreign secretary so
i'm sure we'll come on to it later on
but she has this thing called a network
of liberty strategy which is a strategy
she's produced um
where the uk engages with like-minded
partners not necessarily democracies but
like-minded partners around the world
to counter authoritarian forces like
russia and china and iran to an extent
not that anyone remembers iran anymore
in the context of this conversation so
that puts her at a
uh odds with boris johnson and you could
start to see that fracturing throughout
the last couple of months of the johnson
administration
um i suspect as you've indicated there
and the fact that her team is briefing
out there are a couple of very quick
easy wins one of those is a commitment
to revisit the integrated review and as
your piece reflected on the other day
you know how much actually changes when
you declare an official threat that
remains to be seen will it unify
whitehall into
coming to behind one single china
strategy who knows yeah so so i for
listening sudo i wrote for the spectator
website last week just taking a look at
the implications of this move but some
one thing that i pointed out was that
actually that washington had been very
careful with its own language about
china you know anthony blinken and joe
biden they're not exactly china doves
yet they have said that china is a
challenge or um
something like that rather than a threat
reserving the threat word for russia so
would list trust be going further than
dc if she did do this she would be in
that sense and i think by the way that
reflects a more sophisticated and deeper
uh
u.s china scene than we have in the uk
you know we
can afford to lurch from declaring an
official threat to declaring it a
systemic challenge to declaring a
potentially useful trading partner and
there's not a huge amount of pushback
across the board people just sort of
follow what's said um
putting ourselves at odds with the
american administration on this issue
could be a good thing it could show that
liz trust is willing to sort of lead the
way leave the fight in that regard but
it also could be another fracturous
issue when it comes to foreign affairs
issues we've already got northern
ireland for example where the biden
administration is going to clearly be at
odds with liz truss's own views so
it remains to be seen but again it ties
back to that point you made
what actually changes when you designate
a country as an official thread yeah
well designations might not matter too
much on this particular thing but one
thing that would matter is if she
declares that there's a genocide
happening in xinjiang the region where
the weaker minority in china primarily
live um
sam
she has made it known or her camp or
source is close to her allies close to
trust has have made it known that she
believes that there is a genocide
happening in xinjiang and um i'll just
read this part from a times report from
last year
which said
which is about this row that she had
with caroline wilson our woman in
beijing and the times reported according
to an ally of trust caroline wilson
ended their discussion by asking why the
uk couldn't treat china like we treat
the french according to the source trust
said because the french aren't
committing genocide so a lot of
questions around that first of all
um is she going to declare genocide then
once she becomes prime minister
um it's a great question i suspect
probably not uh to do so would really
compel the uk to follow through a series
of internationally recognized
obligations you know we're assigning to
the un genocide convention
we're assigned to a variety of other
things that mean we have to take active
measures to stop genocide taking place
if we believe generally
it has legal force it has legal
repercussions uh and the americans know
that they've they've done it but they've
not followed through with the legal
obligations that are put upon them um
to the full extent they should have
again please do consult a genocide
lawyer on this i am not going to be able
to offer you particularly strong advice
on this issue but my understanding as it
were and as someone who worked
on the genocide amendment to the trade
pool last year is that when you
officially recognize genocide is taking
place that puts an onus on the country
that has done so to actively try and
stop that using a variety of means that
could include sanctions for example
with all that in mind one can see why
it's a very useful campaign pledge but a
very difficult policy to carry out once
in in power and i think if there was
enough pressure from the back benches
and enough
interest in making a you said this why
aren't you doing this issue then we
could see some trouble here but if truss
and her team have managed to effectively
nullify that um
that caucus of china skeptic mps by
giving them government positions or by
taking a more strongly worded approach
to china that could effectively cut that
issue out before it becomes any bigger
yeah and i want to talk to you about the
backbench mps and those caucuses in a
little while as well um but just staying
on the genocide issue you know you say
that you would have um
obligations to try to stop that
obviously it's a crime against humanity
at the same time it is also difficult to
see how you could justify doing trade
with the genocide or regime um and just
on the question of trade you know you
don't think that she will declare that
but do we know what are the areas that
she thinks is okay to have economic
dialogue with china on because that was
one of the attack points against her
rival rishi sunak that he allowed the
treasury to continue the economic
dialogue with china even as late as this
year so does she not believe in that or
what is it that she believes in when it
comes to the trading relationship sure
so
trust is a view of the trading
relationship from what we can gather
from public comment is that she the key
thing is the uk does not become
strategically dependent on china and
economically dependent too those are
tied together in the mind of the trust
team and the trust administration to go
forward
in terms of what key areas we could
collaborate on that's a that's a million
dollar question actually a multi-million
pound question in many industries
because trust is given no real insight
as to why where she views good trade um
she's been very clear on where china has
economically taken advantage you know be
there at a top level wto the world trade
organization or down to things like ip
theft but she hasn't really indicated
and hasn't needed to indicate where she
thinks the uk can have financial
dialogue with it with china you know the
fact that as you raised there rishi
sunak was
chastised for encouraging the economic
financial dialogue between china and jet
co
i mean that's part of his job obviously
his treasury um as chancellor
but trust hasn't had to indicate where
she thinks that would be a useful area
to talk financially
yeah so that would be one thing that
would be very interesting to see how she
um fleshes it out um one concern that i
have about liz trust's approach to china
is that it often seems quite
performative um so for example you look
at that leak from the truss camp about
the row with caroline wilson that i've
just talked about um i've also written
about the great britain china centre
which you know about sam but for
listeners it's this arms length body of
the foreign office uh set up in 1942
1974 um and basically one of its
functions is to
increase what civil servants call china
capability in westminster's ie talking
to mp civil servants about china um and
not just you know the um the good stuff
also the bad stuff you know we've been
on courses where they've talked about
xinjiang and hong kong all of these
issues that the chinese embassy would
prefer they didn't talk about
nevertheless they do have relations with
the chinese embassy and i've heard from
the trust camp that that is a reason why
that center has been defunded in one of
trust's final acts as foreign secretary
um
now that strikes me as an own goal
it strikes me that at this moment in
time we need to know more about china
rather than less and even tom tukenha
who is you know a key china hawk in in
parliament has written to protest about
it so it's this kind of move that makes
it feel like you know trust isn't
thinking things through
um in terms of a constructive way
forward
rather than just saying if it's chinese
let's shut it down even though the gbcc
wasn't actually chinese um am i being
unfair here
so i share your concerns on the gbcc um
i think that's an incredibly
short-sighted
tactical victory in that it wins support
from china from some china skeptic camps
but you know as you point out tom
tougenhaar isn't backing that as an
ideal choice and i think in this the
long-term sort of strategic vision it's
incredibly short-sighted you
you need to build up uh a knowledge of
china and track two diplomacy which is
what the gbcc also undertakes is an
essential part of that can you explain
what that means sure so my understanding
of track to diplomacy is it sort of back
channel diplomacy uh not always in the
limelight and allows people to have
slightly more open dialogue which is
clearly an essential part of
steering away from pretty horrific
outcomes uh
in terms of liz truss's
approach to the china strategy you know
one of the things that's been thrown
around is she takes a headlines first
policy uh second approach to this sort
of stuff um and that's quite clear you
know if you're going to cut the gbcc
what are you replacing it with if
nothing at all why not can you explain
why not if you can't explain why not
then
the logical conclusion is you need to be
able to sit down and justify that sort
of cut and you know as you pointed out
again in that piece it's not a huge
amount of money they're not it's not 15
billion pounds a year that's costing to
keep this place open we have so few
avenues yeah it's half a million exactly
half a million pounds i mean that is a
posturous amount of money to consider as
an individual but as a as a government
you know what is that nothing at all so
there are a lot of puzzling decisions
and i think you're you're not unfair to
criticize her on that particular point
as prime minister um she will have to be
able to substantiate these sort of
things you know to go back to a point we
slightly touched on earlier about
hawkish language when she discusses
things like taiwan you can't really take
the biden approach of saying you know
we're going to stand with taiwan and
then your department backtracks for you
which he's done a couple of times now
but trust trust has said you know we're
going to arm taiwan and then pressed by
a media she
did this in dallas and doesn't quite
understand what she's talking about or
comes across as not understanding fully
what she's trying to say and that will
not cut it going forward
so well let's look at going forward then
because on the economic front the
spectator has reported about the
economist that she's got around her
these three truskateers we called them
um that basically flesh out her energy
policy i'm glad you're enjoying that
stuff that is a criminal name three
musketeers
and are there going to be um an
equivalent committee of experts for her
china policy or even not just a
committee but you know who will be
informing uh the details because she
will be very very busy she will be very
busy and i think this morning the times
reported that john bu who was boris
johnson's foreign affairs advisor helped
craft the integrated review that you
mentioned earlier on is going to be
carrying on into the trust
administration um she will have people
around her you know if you look at
people like ipac the inter-parliamentary
alliance on china um they have liaise
with uh
sort of trusts not directly in a
one-on-one capacity but people like ian
duncan smith who co-chairs um ipac in
the uk are a close ally of trust they
should potentially have a voice more
represented now and in a trust
government than under johnson's and
bringing people like tom tugginhart into
government as well should
booster her sort of depth when it comes
to understanding the china conundrum if
you will or the china challenge
um
she'll also be able to reflect on a huge
amount of civil service might now that
she is prime minister which she did have
access to as foreign secretary but now
she can set the direction herself she
can set what when she wants briefings
she can set who's giving her the
briefings in terms of her special
advisers i'm not sure we've got a uh
three truscuities type situation yet but
that could all change um you know as you
touch on earlier on
trusses immediate focuses that sort of
twin tigers of
soaring inflation and crippling energy
prices foreign policy has faded into the
background
and one suspects that won't come up in
the near future yeah well when it comes
to the foreign office i have to say i'm
a bit skeptical about how much civil
service might there is i mean obviously
you know as an institution it is has
served us relatively well throughout the
last few hundred years but you know
there also reports that only 14 civil
servants a year are being trained in
mandarin in the foreign office um
it's a shocking
shocking amount of lack of expertise i
personally think and sam when it comes
to let's talk about when it comes to
those two and twin tigers that you're
talking about then
if she doesn't
deliver on the hawkishness that she has
talked with so far on china um you
alluded to earlier that there could be
problems on the back benches so ian
duncan smith someone who at the time of
recording she hasn't set her cabinet yet
um but we don't think he's he's going to
be a cabinet minister so is it people
like that even though they have
supported her so far you know could they
be the kind of hardline brexiteers um
kind of vibe where they are trying to
push her to go ever more strong worded
but once she's got the keys to downing
street she actually will want to mellow
out a little bit more so could they
cause her trouble on the back benches
yeah they definitely could um she'll
have a honeymoon period when she gets in
it won't be that long but she'll have
one but she's made a series of political
contracts with various back benches
about how hawker she's going to be
towards china and each of those back
benches will have a limited amount of
patience before they start questioning
why she's not doing what she said she
would do you know as we discussed
earlier on the genocide thing could be a
significant issue if they so choose to
make it but there are more granular
issues things like hike vision the
chinese surveillance company that
produces cameras used widely throughout
the uk that's been flagged over the last
year and a half multiple times by
backbench mps is something they want
movement on and there is legislation
coming down the line which will have
amendments that cover supply chain bits
and pieces that should be able to help
the government remove hike vision if
they wanted to but if the feeling starts
to set in the trust has you know gone
for the headlines and actually flowed
through a little policy then you could
have people like saying duncan smith
nurse ghani who sits in the business
select committee
uh labour are always happy to come on
board for a bit of government bashing as
lib dems you know as they rightfully
should that is their job but it's it'll
be interesting to see if trust has
managed to nullify enough of the china
hawk camp from the back benches which
you know by the way is not necessarily
reunited by being china skeptics it's
we we all have a skeptical view of china
and we want varying things to take place
and to happen some of those sit in the
china research group like alicia kearns
the 2019er and some of them sit under
the ipac banner uh like i said duncan
smith and between them they have very
differing views of what they want trust
to do so it's going to be difficult for
her to keep all those people in check
and satisfied but i don't know in terms
of timelines how quickly we'll see some
of that movement yeah well
you've already mentioned um to china
research group and ipac and for people
who are luckily not in our world of
uk china policy
please explain what those caucuses are
um
absolutely so the inter-parliamentary
alliance on china which is ipac
was co-founded they were both co-founded
actually beginning of 2020. ipac sits
across many governments uh throughout
the world has many parliamentarians and
government officials uh actually not
government officials but political
officials within it
um
and in the uk it's chaired by sir ian
duncan smith the former conservative
leader and baroness helena kennedy who's
obviously a peer and it has people from
every single party in the uk are as
members so conservative labour liberal
democrats smp
the china research group was founded by
tom tugginhart and neil o'brien
both conservative mps neil would
eventually go into government uh tom
remained on the back bench he's also
chair of the foreign affairs committee
and that was found at around the same
time as ipac and it's just formed of
conservative mps
now ipac would view its role i think
more as an advocating or a lobbying
group that advocates for a very
particular cause
um whereas the china research group
would paint itself potentially more as
an educational body it was about
responding to the increased skepticism
among conservative mps on things like
huawei they both have a a lot of
influence within parliament ipac has a
global footprint that's the big
difference and sam as you mentioned
hikvision is one of those issues that is
not often in the headlines
there are other issues outside of
xinjiang and outside of hong kong that
are concerning and should be concerning
for the british government when it comes
to our relationship with china so what
are some of those other issues and like
hikvision uh that you know this trust
will have to think about
yeah so there are a whole number of them
one of them that's been raised
repeatedly by um some very interesting
voices in this scene if you were are
things like the internet of things the
small components that make up everyday
items people like charlie parton have
been raising that more and more um
that's one of those headaches that you
tackle now and you can deal with it but
if you leave it for another year two
years five years you've got a
significant issue down the road i've
concerns over a similar kind of huawei
issue where we're relying on chinese
tech that's exactly right that has been
typified and i think a lot of these
issues stem from the
[Music]
thing that haunts many policymakers in
the western world which is a potential
chinese invasion or economic blockade of
taiwan you know we talk about
semiconductors as the sort of
central driving force for the next
hundred years in terms of how
governments and societies operate and
the uk like many governments around the
world had to try and work out how much
of its supply chain is at risk to the
semiconductor industry being effectively
based in taiwan and that that filters
down the way other other issues that
i've seen parliamentarians raised before
which could come back onto the agenda
with more aggression are things like bgi
group which is a genomics firm
and you've seen some mps like the
liberal democrats uh asked carmichael
raise the fact that bgi group this big
huge chinese genomics firm which i think
is blacklisted by the american
administration is still operating
throughout the uk so is that like a
23andme kind of thing but run by the
chinese exactly and so that taps into a
base concern which many mps have and you
see it actually with tick tock as well
which is the idea of data and in that
case genetic data being taken from the
british and sent to the chinese to
really simplify it down and once you've
got that concern there you can build and
grow and that touched on tick tock as
well raised during the campaign uh
election she said she would crack down
on it she didn't say what that meant
exactly
that goes back to the point earlier on
it's very easy to say i'm gonna crack
down on this and then not have to show
how that would would actually come into
effect but there's a potential executive
order in america which trust may be
watching maybe keeping a close eye on to
see how the americans do it
in the uk it's unclear you know that
tick tock was mentioned last year in a
business select committee report as a
company that they were worried about um
and it's it's continuing to sort of bug
mps they don't think it's been taken
seriously enough
the china skeptic mps had to complain to
parliament's speaker of the house when
parliament created its own tiktok
account
so
there are lots of these sort of issues
that pop up every now and then i would
like to say there's a strategic theme
that runs through all of them but
actually it's very episodic well
strategic is the key word here because i
have heard of a mythical china strategy
that is meant to have come out after the
integrated review um a sam tell us what
a china strategy would be doing and b um
is it coming
so i'll start with b i have no idea
and go into a the china strategy as it's
been pitched to me by maybe a million
different civil servants officials et
cetera et cetera
it really depends who you ask so liz
trust was taken in front of the foreign
affairs committee a couple of months ago
and she was asked point blank by an mp
what is the china strategy where is it
and she said you know what china's
strategy actually i think we can hear it
now why has the china strategy being
delayed
um i didn't know there was a
can we
not
sorry could you elaborate on we were
told by officials that number of times
that china strategy was due to be
published in june
i'm afraid that
two days ago so you can see there's
confusion even at the top there and
further on in the committee hearing
alicia kern said that actually it's
probably the case that any sort of
chinese strategy hasn't come onto your
desk yet because you're at the top it
might be still being worked on by civil
servants the idea behind the china
strategy um if it exists and as it
exists
is to bring together departments
thinking towards china because right now
if you are in the treasury you have a
very different view of what the uk's
approach to china is and if you do in
the foreign office or the mod the
minister of defense
and that has persisted throughout the
johnson era um
certainly a document of sorts arrived at
one point on boris johnson's desk
but whether that was acted on remains
another great mystery from that
administration's time um so watch this
space we could see something it could be
a very easy uh easy trust win but who
knows yeah and we will find out a lot of
the answers to these questions very very
soon um she's got a lot on her plate but
she will also be going to the g20 summit
in november in bali in indonesia and
allegedly sitting ping is planning on
going as well so maybe we'll see her sit
down and give c a telling off after she
has sat down and called out putin as
well because he's also going to be there
so very exciting times coming up ahead
indeed a busy busy gathering um sam
thank you so much for joining chinese
whisperers and tell us about your
newsletter as well because i have had so
much information on what we've talked
about today from the newsletter so where
can people find it what is it about yada
yada sure thank you well thank you for
having me it's been a real pleasure um i
produce a weekly briefing on uk china
relations specifically about how the uk
is talking about china that's called
beijing to britain and it can be found
at www.beijingtobritain.com
and it is free for all government and
whitehall accounts so do sign up but
even if you're not even if you're not
you can pay a 10 or a month which i
think is absolutely worth it so sam
thank you so much thank you so much
thank you for watching this episode of
chinese whispers if you've just come
across the podcast on youtube you can
find more episodes through searching for
chinese whispers wherever you get your
podcast from there is a brilliant
backlog of episodes not on youtube and
if you have feedback do leave a comment
below preferably constructive and
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel so you never miss any of our
spectator tv shows thanks for watching
[Music]
you